it's
t for one for prince william the duke of
cambridge is carrying on with his royal
duties as his wife
kate middleton continues to self-isolate
following an exposure to covid19
the 39 year old royal hosted the big t
event
on monday solo at buckingham palace
honoring national health service staff
and frontline workers
the occasion the 73rd anniversary of the
nhs england's national health service
and the party was originally supposed to
include
kate but it was announced on sunday that
the mom of three was self-isolating at
home
after coming into contact with someone
who tested positive for covid19
a royal source previously confirmed to
et that the duchess received
both of her vaccinations after going
public with the first one
in late may prior to the news of her
exposure
kate was all smiles as she attended
wimbledon on friday
toured the museum and helped out in the
community kitchen
but despite his wife's absence william
carried out the event
and praised the healthcare heroes for
their tireless work
video of the outdoor gathering was
shared on the cambridge's official
instagram account
earlier in the day the 39 year old royal
attended the service of thanksgiving at
saint paul's cathedral in london
in honor of the special occasion the
queen awarded the george cross award to
the
nhs sharing this handwritten letter on
social media which read in part
quote over more than seven decades and
especially in recent times
you have supported the people of our
country with courage
compassion and dedication demonstrating
the highest stands of public service
you have our enduring thanks and
heartfelt appreciation
the george cross is awarded for acts of
heroism in circumstances of extreme
danger
and it's the uk's highest award for
non-military courage
meanwhile william's brother prince harry
has returned home to california from the
uk
after reuniting with his brother for the
unveiling of the princess diana statue
in honor of what would have been their
late mother's 60th birthday
of course the reunion was a big deal as
it came amid reports that the two
brothers are at
odds following harry's decision to step
back from his senior royal duties in
2020
and his explosive tell-all interview
with oprah winfrey earlier this year
there's clearly still a lot of hurt a
lot of resentment
and a degree of mistrust i think on both
parts
but i think the hope is that come july
when we are hoping to see the brothers
stand once again shoulder by shoulders
that the relationship will be
stronger and in a better place the
statue unveiling marked the first time
the brothers had publicly come
face to face since april when they
attended the funeral of their
grandfather prince philip
diana always said to them always stay
close
don't ever fall out she would be
devastated that that is what happened
and she would be wanting them to feed
her together for that unveiling of the
statue in her honor
et spoke to royal expert katie nichol
after the brothers reunited
she weighed in on the significance of
the day of course as much
as everyone wanted to see what the
statue looked like
all eyes were on william and harry and
their body chemistry
and how they were interacting with each
other so as they
arrived at the sunken garden at
kensington palace they were walking
side by side and they were engaged in a
conversation
i watched it and thought how comfortable
they looked in each other's company
there wasn't any sign of
of any tension now i think both of them
have wanted today to be about the statue
about remembering diana's legacy and not
about the rift that has really
overshadowed the coverage
of the royal family for the past 18
months now so
they clearly went to a lot of effort to
deflect from this rift
between the two of them and instead to
project on
their mother a legacy and crucially
putting on a united front to remember
diana
their mother on what would have been her
60th birthday
you